another reminder that the World Cup is
on sorry Brazil hello welcome to gam
spots Lobby every Tuesday 2 p.m. right
here on gamespot.com how you doing you
enjoying the World Cup well you're
probably not if you're Brazilian but
don't worry about it we're going to talk
about video games today if you want to
Inn some codes for the ridiculous Humble
Bundle that's happening we're going to
be giving them away later in the show
also got Jeremy Jan on to play the
forest plus it's July so what better
time to talk about Game of the Year got
a all our Gamespot editors on the show
later uh to look at the hottest
contenders uh for that so yeah look
forward to it don't worry about it we
got games coming out in the summer as
well my name is Daniel DWI delighted to
be joined by Chris Waters
well well hello Chris is dead Chris
disappeared when um when America got
kicked out of the World Cup so uh we've
got mared fully recovered no and Pete
and Teresa are sandwiched between us the
developers of this uh this ridiculous
game that has taken I feel like most of
my yeah there you go yeah make him feel
real uncomfortable imagine if I was
Chris Waters that's true he'd be all
over you at Turtle sbox you turtle
sandbox sorry you guys released Cannon
brawl which myself Mary been playing a
bunch of for the past couple of weeks
bet yesterday today out there how long
you guys been working on this bad boy
almost 3 years oh really what's it like
cuz you guys have been in Alpha for a
while right almost a year almost a year
what what's it been like in the past 24
hours getting the beta out there what's
the reception been like so far it's been
really good it's
been people are responding almost as
well as when we origin were oh really
that's that's pretty crazy have you seen
the numbers kind of spike a bit is it
that weird like critical mass thing
where people are like I don't want to
touch an alpha but once it's in beta
it's like yeah we cool it that way sweet
all right well to be honest I feel like
this the type of game that kind of works
best oh hey joh thanks very much bro uh
when um when you actually see how it's
being played so let's uh hop right in uh
Teresa you're going to you're going to
play some campaign mode after this we're
going to get you guys to play each other
and then after that because myself and
Mary have been playing a bunch of this
uh this bad boy we're going to get us to
uh to play each other do you guys not
miked up for that whole thing amazing I
love it World Cup baby who knows what's
going on what's the score now 12 nil
poor Brazil
I think that something that's kind of
interesting is a lot of times when you
see a game like this that's so polished
you think wow you know like uh a team
probably came together and made this I
find it pretty fascinating the team is
literally just the two you guys oh
really there is no one else in the
studio besides two people just uh just
lead artist you get to be lead artist
when you're the only artist and lead
programmer yep and that's it can you
just give us like a kind of a a basic
idea of the like moment to moment What's
Happening Here uh sure so in this game
you it's it's a real-time strategy game
but it's it's also very action oriented
and usually the first thing in any
strategy game is you got to build up
your economy this game this level is
teaching you a lot about this game that
you're going to fly an Airship you're
going to build these gold mines now
you're learning about the dire situation
your kingdom is
in I think I I think I learned something
great it looks dire just get XP for that
this is brilliant it's like Call of Duty
didn't kill anyone and I got 75 XP got
an achievement for turning it
on H what I liked about it is not to be
super reductive or anything but it
reminds me of like I'm a massive fan of
worms uh had it on the Amiga 600 when it
originally came out uh and I'm also a
massive fan of Starcraft and it seems to
kind of mix the economy resource
management of a Starcraft game with the
with the sort of I don't know like the
fact you're actually making the shots
yourself instead of just getting dudes
to do for you it's it's a really new
kind of genre I've heard like it
described as a mix of almost every
strategies type game like someone the
other day was saying oh it's a blend of
DOTA two and scorched Earth and and bits
of Prince of Persia here and Gears of
War FS versus zombies and when you
working on this because it when I when I
started playing it it very much felt
like the type of game that I don't know
it's familiar but it's obviously
different because it's using I don't
know systems that perhaps people are
used to uh you guys surprised at all
that this type of game had never been
sort of made before because it is like
this type of competitive multiplayer
game seems so uh I don't know ubiquitous
at the moment it's like everywhere but
like never just in this like sort of 2D
plane yeah yeah I and it it kind of
solves the problem of like how do you
make a complicated RTS approachable but
still have a lot of depth yeah I think a
lot of that is your your your animation
style as well like it's seems very
approachable yeah just say no Starcraft
2 lots of stuff happening on screen at
once kind of thing uh let's just kind of
explain what's happening cuz I think for
folks maybe who were watching this
without actually playing it's a little
bit what's happening confusing the
balloons blue area is kind of like your
area of where you're able to build right
so Teresa is flying her Airship around
that has that that blue ring around it
and she she has built up her economy she
built two gold mines right in the
beginning and now she's placing a cannon
and in this game you with your Airship
you dock with each building and then you
aim it and then you fire it and her
ultimate goal is to blow up the enemy
headquarters which is now on fire so
none of those cannons uh will fire
automatically or uh no so she she gets
to coordinate where they're going to
attack and they're all on a cool down so
there's a little bit of a time
management
multitasking type this is my favorite
part when it slowly Zooms in on the
Victory and then each sort of Airship uh
sort of dictated by who you pick uh has
a different special move as well is that
right right they all all the airships
have different abilities some are some
are active abilities that you actively
use and some are more passive style
abilities and then I've saw as well I
guess in these early levels it's very
much like these are the uh tools at your
disposal you've got a mine you've got
the balloons you've got a cannons uh as
the game progresses uh what I really
enjoyed was that uh you kind of get that
aspect of Dota 2 comes in where you're
basically picking your right you know
instead of picking Heroes you're picking
your loadad for what what you're going
to use um trying to come up with the
most effective combo for the M the map
for the map and then also kind of like
for when you're doing the multiplayer
stuff which we'll we'll get to later on
um like the different ways you can win
the game are like completely different
like I was playing terresa last week uh
at an event we had downstairs and she
was just using like Banks to steal my
godamn like cannons and stuff y like
that's some hot [__] I like built up
all this stuff and then sudden he was
like okay yeah I need to now be
attacking these Banks instead of you
know really dark way to to be victorious
as well is to use a bank to repossess
items that have been purchased to me
that's that's a very real way to win
video game no I left I left Ireland when
the B when the the housing market
crashed it was pretty bad you know
repossessing my cannons we have a lot of
social commentary oh my God all right so
what do we what are we doing here we've
got a one of your mines is on fire
that's tragic there must be a lot of
miners in there just burning to death
slowly so um Teresa is chose chose an
Airship this time that has a active
ability so she could fly underneath that
Cannon and then destroy the land
underneath it favorite of all of them
yeah it's pretty powerful especially in
ones where there's like Islands floating
you can just tell make one collapse the
whole way there probably doing a lot of
balancing right now to make sure that
anything that you add at this stage
isn't too op or cuz you guys are
currently in Early Access um I'm sure
you have users uh giving you points or
yelling at you anytime you make any kind
of changes in the game how much yelling
is happening we're actually like so
grateful for our community because they
we have some really dedicated players
who are way better at the game than we
are oh really oh yeah and we'll we'll
like post these long threads with like
really deep analysis this on the balance
and they're usually right so we just
make the tweaks and let thanks dudes
keep going checks in the
mail all right it looks like you got
this one wrapped up I'll be honest it's
looking pretty good finish him finish
him what I liked as well is that for for
the for the most part when I was playing
this I was trying to slowly make my way
through killing every single building
but then there are sometimes where you
can literally just launch one right over
the top if you get the right angle like
just completely them yeah there's
something really satisfying about taking
out completely cleaning them M and
taking out every building but you really
don't have to you just have to get it is
fun though all right you guys I want you
to play each other let's get into some
we we've seen the sort of early game you
know general based level mechanics of
how this works uh you guys play each
other myself and Mary will try as best
as possible to shoutcast this and then
we're going to have a CO after today all
right so who you who you picking first
of all Teresa you I'm going to take the
Minette she's got a a frost ability she
can uh freeze the opponent's buildings
on cool down what about you Pete I'm
choosing the Taskmaster because they
sometimes can activate the building
twice in a row that's pretty cool I
don't think I've unlocked that dude is
that like an later game thing uh yeah
you unlock that that's in the Armory is
it yes God damn it are there any um
particular Pilots that you need to have
a certain choice to go along with
them and you like make the mistake of
choosing a certain type of pilot and
then not not having the accompanying
yeah no they're they're pretty generaliz
although I I have to say the the um the
minion that does a lot of terrain damage
if you combo that with your uh bomb Bots
that will kind of walk along the bottom
of the train that can kind of be a a bad
combo because you can create a canyon
and then your bomb Bots will just walk
down into the C I was totally doing that
a couple days ago
style all right so what did you guys
pick for your loadouts Teresa what you
got there um I've got the missile Tower
I like it CU I can carpet bomb and not
even worry about aim too much and um and
and uh the driller there's heavy
strategy I like the driller going especi
there's one mission that took me forever
to get the three medals on where there
was a I think it's the last one actually
second to last where the castle is just
up in the top right and I just realized
all I had to do is get the driller
anywhere close to that guy two shots and
it's like the H way down again yeah if
you can get that uh that drop damage so
they've already each built two mining
camps and they're already starting to
acquire some serious funds so oh I
thought said funds sorry
well they are having funs so the diamond
stuff that's like how much better is
that than the mines is that like twice
as much or is like 1.5 okay yeah that's
although I was about to dig to the
diamonds and then Teresa used her
Airship to cancel the laser
oh some pretty high-end strategy that
you will not be seeing from Danny and
myself later on in the game I'll be
mostly sheding hold mck and trying to
fire Rockets from my homebased the
entire only strategy is to yell yeah I'm
a terrible person
uh okay we got diamonds Happening Here
down the Bott great Teresa got into the
diamonds how much uh how much like clout
within the office is going to be based
on winning this live stream game all of
it okay no sweat
guys oh the okay that's the the missile
oh for carbo bombing missile splits into
many shot man you're doing a lot of
lasers I always go for one laser is it
is it like a good I don't know idea to
have as much of the map covered by them
as possible um I need a laser to put
pressure on this mine which will her to
try and defend it and then I need
another laser to put pressure down there
and which will split her attention
hopefully wow Teresa you don't have
Shield do you I don't I there's way a
shield at this moment yo why didn't you
build a shield what's wrong with you
don't you play this video game I tend to
not be a big uh defense player I like to
just push out my offense quite a lot and
see if it works you got to hide your
bias Danny where's your Shield but
that's the thing like I've never played
Without a shield the idea of even doing
it I'm Terri terrified to me I'm I
always choose a shield it's like my
first thing that I have to get when I
play so I find this I find Teresa's
aggressive strategy really we're going
to get caught in a in like a shield
stalemate where it's just the two of us
protecting our minds so that our miners
can live fruitful lives yes why don't we
just build a Utopia and decide to live
harmoniously together and I'm going to
kill I really want to have a like a
achievement that you can get if you
bring all all peaceful buildings all
defense and then just
hold out the stalemate
achievement oh shoot I lost my mind the
other thing I love about this is what
happens in the sort of the end game of
the good worms games which was that the
terrain then becomes an active part of
winning or losing but that only ever
happen like right at the end of the game
of worms whereas it seems to be like a
fundamental thing in this and it's
almost like you guys have designed a
level with that with that in mind
yes he's attacking he is attacking the
castle he's going
your SH now she's down to half this
could be it I just Ed my um Taskmaster
that CH his laser right right away you
guys know when the game is up now my
gosh game is about this is about it's
about over in 5 seconds for that Central
laser and we're done
Shield that's it it's done oh good game
that was a good game unlucky Teresa who
is now apparently going to be giving me
advice on what to do now all right while
before we do that I got bunch of
questions herein asking on the twitch
chat is there a range of map sizes um
they're all about this size some are a
little smaller we think like it's really
important to see everything on one
screen the game is kind of about like
perfect information and how much you can
process at one time so you can kind of
see it all at one time and Monster kitty
Game Spot how long is the game uh I've
completed the the um exhibition part of
it which I don't know felt like it took
maybe two or 3 hours are you guys
focusing on that or is it more so on the
the multiplay more on the multiplayer so
there's the exhibition then there's
nightmare mode then there is as much
multiplayer as you can handle I remember
what
sucks like it's good [__] sucks
Danny's more of an exhibitionist so he
prefer to play the exhibition level oh
is that what I did I'm sorry I'm the
worst I swear to God nightmare mode is
just like it's killing me I love I don't
know how familiar you are with US
presidents Danny why but I'm putting
one is that a Benjamin on this game is
that is that a Lincoln I'm going to
start Lincoln Park the tower he never
told a lie I'm going to win try a new
map yeah you going to do a different map
you think I've mixed up all the
presidents he'll never
know combine them all one giant
president The Lincoln Lawyer L which was
that wasn't Matthew MCC a president of
he was the Lincoln lawar I like this one
all right all right
okay I think I might have done something
you did you darn goof I did done all
right I'm here you in all right okay I'm
going for driller I like wa do it if
he's doing driller then should maybe do
king oh yeah she might good point he
got somebody put up a shield I always go
for now is mining camp yeah PR Cannon
Tower sheld and then sometimes it's like
yeah go for a driller and no it's all
right so I like a he did the driller the
laser might be a little tough cuz
there's that big
colum right the middle you could do the
Demolisher that's a good one the sorry
Chang the name to bomb it's B Frost
to pointless I'm familiar with it okay
good it's kind of like
laser why be can I not use the balloons
you can change the balloon one as well
I'm going to go fortif five no no no no
no what am I doing what am I doing what
back back up back scroll down wor about
mine let's let's look at all our options
you know what I need to there's so much
preparation going in the Stream are just
like play each other godamn
it accelerator I like accelerator
American currency I think that's
technically illegal it's worth so much
right now come and get me coppers are
you an aggressive player or a defensive
player I'm
aggressive the accelerator is good it's
a little expensive it uh but go for it
okay I like using that yeah I want to
get the jump on her we need to BU as
close as we can okay all right Kish
let's do it for $1 oh yeah or perhaps
two it's on 99 Cents after tax you ain't
no king of me all right Irish people
know a lot of fighting against Kings you
expand to the top okay yeah this is
great I can hear him giving her advice
it won't it won't save you
man me I'm ahead of you in the bottom
yeah you can get the bottom one as well
marry ahead of you come on oh God damn
it God damn it my CPM look at
him then put a frost yeah we start doing
the bomb Bots right away okay okay got
just a little pressure on her or Shields
aren't going to be super effective
against you can see if she's going to
now shoot the don't don't shoot yeah get
one of those out right ahead should
that's good and then fire that and that
one is getting the cool down bonus from
your
accelerator okay now build a
flamethrower you bu the very
front really you just want to like
really spam those bombs like as much as
possible pressure on almost almost
upgrade it UPG all right I didn't I shot
it yo Mary how you going over there yes
better KN Frost FR you know what I'm
going to use I'm going to use should I
upgrade uh you can't yet but you missed
in the way all right use that
Canon oh good you got it right before it
got frost that was good oh my gosh he's
going after me what's up okay you can
put another bomb put another bomb you've
got 60 you can afford it I did cuz you
want to have as much stuff as you can I
not have gotten it you don't have to we
want to aim towards their
build and then your drill is ready to go
you can drill um drop damage on yeah
exactly cuz if you can get that one to
drop all the way way down it could take
when we do the swim upgrade some of
these bad boys up I would do the front
ones CU to the is really going to oh it
feels so good Danny upgrade your oh your
tears they're so juicy I want to put a
bomb over towards your headquarters
because it'll be out of range of the my
flamethrower is going to and then
upgrade that one go get another one get
ready with another one will The Shield
stop the flamethrowers no not too I mean
a little bit it block it'll block them
Denny
I I would put that bombb next to the
headquarters though Danny as far forward
as far forward as you can your death is
inent intimate intimate up it's a very
intimate intimate death sign me up now
Frost God damn it you're using
hack [__] this all right okay you want
to get I've never heard Talent be called
that before okay you're right I need
flamethrower again [__] flame Dr and
go do one well at least you got the
Fortified mine it's going to be a lot
better
out of range now keep that one firing as
often as you can and you can
upgade and then keep that uh that one
firing yeah yeah Hur you got it good
build on the get another flamethrower
those those flamethrowers are really low
on health so you can keep
those forward as you can I'll just make
the trick with the flamethrower is like
you have to invest a lot into thanks
coach where they
are
youring oh well you know what I got to
take out her economy over here you
bam oh my God he took out my economy
yeah all those all those miners they're
all dead now it's fine it's fine okay
don't hit the shield with that guy too
yeah that's
good my econom
burn easy easy P oh my God we had we had
to stop that tomorrow burn him you know
what you know what I'm going to go I'm
going to take some risky strategy here
yeah I'm crazy yeah I'm crazy I just
want to I want a shocker that's all I
want oh no that's not going to work
that's not going to work personal I'm
okay I'm uncomfortable you're yeah my
miners just want to mine and fund their
family look at this I'm going to blow
you
up I'm slowly going to eat away at you
down here
look you you just wait and see right
can't go any further let's build a frost
tower on your on that Teresa I really
want that dollar you're not making this
any easier he doesn't make a lot of
money I don't he needs that money keep
everything burning keep it all going had
it nearly had it there you go keep
everything burning sounds like Mary Kish
all right Frost that burn that turn that
on turn that on turn that on and you got
a frost start way in the back God damn
it a little rough looking pretty bad
isn't it it's looking pretty dire all
right you took out a flamethrower though
that was good oh no I I don't even have
the ability to get over there now that's
really
depressing just just yeah just start
shooting your stuff just start shooting
up Mary you know all about that don't
you oh my gosh you got so first that's
right I just gave you access to a mine
yeah that was that was a good
it's okay it's okay it's okay keep keep
your uh everything firing right there a
little present coming for you there
[__] oh no but the shield is far
forward as you
can see see see I'm was planning it all
along I'm going to that again but it as
close as you can this episode of Lobby
became famous because it lasted 4 hours
towards that Cannon yeah cuz the
flamethrowers shoot through the ground
yo what's up yep there we go don't hit
the sh yeah that's get Frost I put
another I'd put another bomb and if you
you know what if you can make that hole
go through on the bottom and then get
the bombs going down there he's coming
after my stuff he's coming after my
goods but the bombs won't go up so just
concentrate on pushing the bottom to the
right build a flamethrower but you did
uh that was good that youest that
territory so she can't there flame blow
him you might want to um sell your level
three Cannon get the money put down more
B I can sell we actually wait till you
get the whole all the way through at the
botom put that as close as you can now
we
can a couple more
shots block that with your Canon you Dam
it you stole my mine and I can't build
there you were the
worst so sad typical typical royalty
okay now you can build at the bottom on
oh on that yeah get the gold oh it's get
can you like Brazil Danny you like it
you like Brazil I don't I don't like
Brazil why you keep saying that oh
godamn it D you have tons of money as
many bombs on the bottom as you can okay
and push them as far out too and then
just keep them firing make sure
everything's shooting and you can
upgrade them
because he's really they're really
shooting the crap at him I didn't know
that you could do frost and fire to such
oh my God he's coming out do that so our
main goal is we need to upgrade that
okay send that one on the bottom don't
worry about the top really yeah get them
all going on the
bottom keep going more bombs there yeah
you have you're going to have 60 by the
time you get back there Teresa is
dangerous oh you know what I've got I've
got this thing flamethrower in the
middle uh yeah good that's perfect oh no
okay out yeah and don't hit the shield
yep you're perfect right there how do I
upgrade make sure that doesn't go in can
we need some money and then you can push
out for the money on the bottom too I
can yeah he's coming after me but push
out using another bomb so grab a bomb
which one this
one
so I got no money to sorry yeah this one
that next time next time you have 60
push that one out on the bottom be real
with me dude this is T almost there
we're almost there this is this is video
games right here put a gold mine in
front of that feel like we have a chance
shoot yeah do it money games man money
games all the way forward all the way
forward keep them firing okay I'm
actually putting that there just to buy
me some time I was blocked by his
terrain no you can put on mine down
there I'm going to die and then keep
that fire go I got to go for it is this
the biggest comeback in video game
history is that what's Happening Here
Brazil yeah fire
one by our
headquarters
yeah look at that look at that I was
Brazil that was brilliant I didn't I
didn't realize that bottom strategy was
going to work out so well that was great
yo yo make it rain Make It Rain make it
drizzle just a little bit all right next
time we get him next time all about the
Benjamin's baby it's a Washington all
right I think we may have done a good
job of explaining I'm going to spend
this you know what in the world of CBS
games with our wonderful vending
machines this is four cans of Diet Coke
right here my dentists will be delighted
um I think we did a good job of kind of
explaining how fun that goddamn game
could be for the folks at home who want
to get in on the action uh when is canab
braw available for how much it's
available right now on Steam and it is
40% off right now for sweet so it's only
$60 only $60 worth every penny and much
is it how much is it actually it's uh
$8.99 $8.99 I only got two payments
left yeah make that three it's just the
beta right now just the beta right now
so you guys you're still adding in uh
functionality yeah uh extra levels all
that sort of stuff right up until final
release sweet which is when which is
coming up at the end of August sweet all
right a great summer indoors then for
you guys awesome uh thanks very much for
coming on really appreciate it let's get
you on again uh close to launch and and
maybe Mary might actually win a game oh
we'll practice my pride Let's do let's
do a let's do $10 then H we'll be back
in a couple of minutes with uh Our Round
Up of the halime of game of the year uh
right after this trailer I believe for
the Humble Bundle H money money
money
introducing the a humble 2K bundle it's
pay what you want redeems on Steam eight
awesome games and helps charity pay $20
or more and get XCOM Enemy
Unknown and BioShock
Infinite okay more than the price and
get BioShock
Mafia about time he showed
up and spec Ops the Line cia's been here
for God knows how long trying to clean
it up if we're going to sort this out we
need to find John Conrad or pay $1 or
more and get the Darkness
2 I'm stronger than you
think the bureau XCOM
Declassified we must make it our own
their weapons will become our
weapons and
BioShock
a customizable portion of each purchase
will be going to support action against
hunger and the American Red
Cross so don't delay head over to
humblebundle.com today tweet about it
Facebook share it like this video on
YouTube and sprinkle a little lemon on
our Google
pluses
what what's a Google Plusle God damn it
if you want to win one of those we're
giving away a bunch of codes for The
Humble Bundle all you have to do is
retweet a tweet that the Gamespot
account did uh at about 2:15 I believe
uh so just go back on our Gamespot
Twitter account also you need to make
sure that you're following us so that we
can spam you so that we can send you uh
the details in a direct message see it
makes sense Bioshock the bureau Darkness
2 BioShock 2 Mafia 2 spec Ops the Line
and also it'll include XCOM Enemy
Unknown and BioShock Infinite which is a
game Tomic sh
hates I kind I kind of hate it too yeah
yeah yeah yeah I like it do you like it
I like no I like it it's great so what
does that mean does that mean 5.01 gam
is that where we're at Zer 210 how
scores are decided video games we're not
here to talk about like the worst games
of last year we're here to talk about
the best games of this year we are here
to talk about the best games released in
2014 so far Tomic Shake carollyn p and
Justin hawald we got a bunch of games to
talk about today but you folks are on to
talk about three in particular first of
all a DLC pack yeah so we're starting
with kind of a weird one we're going to
start by talking about The Last of Us
left behind and um it may or may not you
know be eligible for the actual game of
the year award that Gamespot gives at
the end of this year but we we wanted to
talk about it Tom and I I think in
particular are big champions of this
game because we just think that it's one
of the greatest achievements of the year
so far um it's it is just remarkable
storytelling I don't know a lot of
people have haven't really gotten around
to it yet I've noticed yeah me included
actually they might be waiting for uh I
mean Last of Us PS4 is coming out this
month so but it's I mean it's flushes
out the story in the character Ellie
who's one of the best characters ever
just in a way that the main game wasn't
quite able to do right so I mean the the
core game The Last of Us I think you
know you is an excellent example of like
really traditional um kind of AAA action
adventure game design where you play
through a section of and then there's
like a like story cut scenes and then
you play through another section there's
more cut scenes part of what makes left
behind I think so um brilliant is the
way that it uses the gameplay mechanics
that you kind of get familiar with
throughout the Last of Us in different
ways to build up the the feeling you
have as the player of this Bond uh
between Ellie and and her friend Riley
and so it just kind of you know rather
than using stealth to like hide from
clickers or you know the things you did
in the normal game it's like now you're
playing a game of hide andek with your
friend or you know tosing bricks at cars
is this like moment of of bonding and
the um it's also important to just say
that the quality of the writing in this
is truly exceptional as far as games
writing goes it it really does put the
writing in most games to shame and you
feel the bond between these two
characters in a way that you just
normally don't don't feel those things
in games that's that seems to be often
the case in some DLC Packs now where
because the stories are sort of more
they're they're shorter and more Compact
and they can sort of play with that song
do you guys think that this is a game
that perhaps you need to have played the
last of us really appreciate you have to
have played through the last of us but
but I think that's one of the things
that because of like because there are
spoiler implications in it as well right
yeah mostly because of the spoilers like
this is this takes part as partly a
prequel partly something that's going on
while the the main game is going on uh I
I think they're really smart with the
way they handled it though that it's not
trying to extend overextend the story of
The Last of Us which ended in such a
good way like this is something that is
a great way to to continue that
enjoyment of the game exactly kind of
kind of inform your understanding of of
Ellie as a person of things that she's
been through in some ways before the
last of us the things that make her who
she is excellent and it's coming out the
PlayStation 4 Definitive Edition will
contain this as well so that'll be a
great chance for anyone who didn't play
The Last of Us to to play that as well
as Left Behind yeah or for for folks
like myself who played The Last of Us
who are just looking for an excuse to go
through it again and who missed this
yeah um I'm I'm really looking forward
to it that's I really want to go through
it on Hardcore difficulty like I've just
been waiting it's like oh no I have an
excuse that's good call well from a Sony
exclusive to a Nintendo exclusive Mario
Kart 8 came out last month it was the
almost the soundtrack of our office for
about two weeks as Tom you were playing
it people were getting involved in it um
a lot of some people think you know just
another Mario Kart why why do you think
this might be one of the best games
released this year uh you can make a
strong case that this is the best Mario
Kart ever from a pure racing perspective
okay um you could not make a strong case
if that's not true meaning this is this
this is just the best pure racer
Nintendo has has made or published since
f-zero basically uh which was which was
a while ago because like they there's
nothing else in this game except for
racing there's none there's no like
challenges or anything which we've seen
in other games like the DS version but
like they nailed the momentto moment
feel of driving so much and they nailed
the course design and it's just it's
it's really just a masterpiece in like
that regard of like they understood how
to make driving really fun and balanced
and on top of that I think it's also
worth noting that the the design the
visual design of the game is just so so
vibrant and so beautiful I mean I I get
a similar feeling when I'm playing this
game and riding around the tracks to
when I'm on like a ride at Disneyland
and there's all these wonderful like at
Splash Mountain or whatever there's all
these wonderful details everywhere these
tracks have a similar feeling of just
kind of cartoonish life to them you know
you get a sense of just this whole world
that kind of stretches out around you
that's um just so IM
and that you just want to be in you know
and one of the things that's very
popular about Mario Kart games
especially with sort of the younger
audiences who might have their first
experience of any Mario Kart is playing
with others is there anything
necessarily in this version that kind of
makes it stand out in terms of its
multiplayer it's fair okay it's really
fair because I mean I fair not as in
like it's it's okay but fair is in
balanced and fair it's really balanced
cuz like while I was reviewing this I
went back and played Double Dash and
like this past weekend I was playing uh
Wii with my niece and like those games
are super broken because they want like
they want everybody to be competitive
and so if you're really good you keep
getting hamstrung by that kind of like
rubber band AI whereas this if you're
good you can just stay in first and like
it feels so satisfying to like get
getting first if you're behind someone
because you earned it and I I really
love that the blue shell in other games
has always been so ridiculously
overpowered and in this game they give
you the power to to overcome that they
there's an item specifically where you
know you sound a horn and that will
repel the blue shell as it comes to
attack you and some people have also
found that you're able to boost if you
boost just right at the right time you
can get right past the blue shell the
blue shell is super rare like maybe
maybe once per race maybe the horn Ian
didn't turn up that often you didn't
need it that often either that's it's as
rare as the blue shell weirdly but I
mean the lightning is is more prevalent
but like that's not a huge detriment so
it's it really just feels like it's
focused on racing and I love that and
some I don't know if I agree with this
but you have these anti-gravity section
now and people feel like maybe I don't
even need FZ because this kind of fills
that itches that scratch sh does not not
unless they bump this up to
500cc H that's Mario Kart 8 um got one
more guys for you uh sorry one more game
for you guys before I send you off and
we rejig this with Kevin and and Shawn
mcginness uh we have obviously doing um
game of the month here at gamespot.com
some of these games that we're going to
talk about today have won game at a
month some haven't because some months
are stronger than others um our most
recent one uh was shovel kn which one of
you guys actually played I
reviewed I reviewed all three of these
games coincidentally I review only the
best games who's also Carol who's in
charge of the game of the year documents
we have on be this guy right here yeah
he's got his he's got his fingers in all
the pies I I my fingers are sticky and
full of fruits so why I haven't played
this all car have you played this all I
I only actually scratched the surface of
it and immediately it it just felt it
felt like to me like it could have been
a classic you know NES game like If This
Were game that actually come out the NES
because it it captures kind of that that
Mega Man or you know Sid scrolling feel
but it also has this kind of world map
thing these Villages you go into that
are very reminiscent of Zelda 2 The
Adventure of link and and so it just it
just uh it takes all of these familiar
elements from those games but it it
pulls them off so well that you know
it's just wonderful to return to them
it's like if people were still making
NES games this is the game that they
would have made this is the Natural
Evolution extension is there something
different than about cuz you know you
can say that you know remakes of old NES
games could be something quite tce or
what is it about this is this more than
just a simple homage is it is it
actually something that feels like it
could have been released there that's
actually the the beauty of it is this
this doesn't have anything else to it
like Super Time Force one of the other
like great games of the year like that
couldn't have been made like that was
that's completely new and inventive with
the time mechanic but this really is
just old school this is what NES games
were but it's a really good version of
what NES games were and I kind of like
that they are so confident of what that
design is they're just like no this is
this is it there's no gimmicks there's
no twist it's just a really awesome NES
game but it uses a very modern mindset
like I don't feel like someone could go
into it now and go like oh this just
feels super old I don't want to play it
like it it borrows ideas of of game
design like it doesn't have lives it's
not like one of those old oh I didn't
make it I'm going to die and now I have
to restart the entire game it has
checkpoints to kind of allot Dark Souls
it doesn't punish you extraneously for
dying like you're able to go and get any
gold that you lose back you it's not a
punishing game like those old NES ones
were this is true we've talked about a
couple there obviously there are way
more games out there that have been
released this year that that have made
our list that we will definitely be
talking about this is by no means a
comprehensive look at all of the best
games of this year so three games is the
list this is it so what I want to do is
I want to give you all a moment just to
let us know what game you would pick
right now if you were in charge Justin
why would you oh what favorite game
released in the past six mon you could
start with me go down there left behind
I already know car so oh mine is
Kentucky rout zero oh really okay I did
not I put I thought you going to say
Child of Light uh no Child of Light is
Child of Light is great but I but
Kentucky R zero I think is really
something special it's another it's
again a bit of an odd one because it's
being released in chapters um and it's
only the third out of five so far did
the first one come last year I feel
first two oh first two okay yeah they're
very far apart but I think it's a an
absolute Masterpiece excellent that's
Kentucky root zero for all our friends
in Europe sure
and Justin awal I it's it's so hard
Titanfall Titanfall Justin awal thinks
Titanfall Titanfall say it is that true
no no no I Titanfall is really good it's
so hard to to choose right now TI
Titanfall is something that I'm really
enjoying hearth stone you also really
like if I had to pick one it would be
hearstone go it's not even a video game
it's not even out yet out yet it is out
I don't even know what I and it is a
video game
that it's not a video game being on
mobile doesn't make it not a game dud no
it's pretty good I wish I was good at it
that's that's how we know it's a video
game because i' I've envy and wish I was
good at it h we'll be back in a second
uh we have a bunch of more game ofe
stuff to talk about uh but I believe a
new trailer for battleborn came out
today yes check it
out
I'm
to
you star
plan
calling
the the
way
you I'm on my I'm
on I'm
on
borne featuring the vocal stylings of
M83 before we talk about the game of the
year I want all three of you Tom McShay
Kevin vanard sea mcginness to review
that trailer first Tom go uh it it's
it's not polished enough it might uh
when Kevin vanord forced me to watch
that trailer I wasn't quite sure if I
was the one I don't know score a 10 for
the trailer the three Okay Kevin Four
four man what's the reviewer's tilt on
that what is show goodness I like the
part where the arrow is about to hit the
bug but then the lady comes out and he's
like not today bug you get to live to
see another day great well there you go
Battle Board who knows lots of love
fors that might be our game of the year
uh talk later this year who knows but
anyway we're here to talk about the best
games released in 2014 very happy to be
joined with Tom M Shake Kevin vanard and
sha mckinness gentlemen
yeah there are a lot of good games came
out this year one of the ones that I
have on my list only came out last week
in fact Kevin you were on this very show
playing it Divinity original s so you I
guess you like it then it's really
really good it's really really long oh
wow okay that's why we like it good and
long so we didn't get review code of it
so I'm still playing this game I picked
it up at the same time everybody else is
leveling real slowly making my way oh
eight oh wow really you've played for
like a 100 hours I feel like I I haven't
actually played as much as I as I've
needed to because I actually had I tried
to have a little bit of a life this last
weekend over the holiday but uh well
we're we're going to do a review in
progress at some stage just for the
moment what is it about this game that
thinks it could be a contender for best
game of the year oh it's the the
combat's really good number one it's got
turn-based combat like it's like from
Temple of ele Elemental Evil kind of was
way back in the day except not broken
Okay so
that's really good the exploration
really neat um there's quests everywhere
you go there's something to do and the
interesting thing is the game doesn't
hold your hand for any of this stuff
like there are no real every so often
like a waypoint type thing will appear
but typically no way points there's lots
of different ways to solve quests
depending on how you go about things
sometimes you can talk your way out it
has this cool rock paper scissors system
when you have two characters talking to
to each other and Bas but but that in
itself is sort of based on their stats
for like I'm going to try to out charm
you oh I'm going to try to out
intimidate you so we're going to do rock
paper scissors to and sometimes you do
that against like enemies and suddenly
it's like oh I don't have to fight these
dudes they're like oh I Charmed my way
into their Lair and uh I I don't know
usually when someone has a lair you
don't have to do much Charming to get in
there well you know no trying to get you
into their Lair I I magied my way into
that can I ask a question about the
co-op yeah how's the co-op so the
co-op's good it's interesting because
the the co-op is actually one of the
single player irritations that might not
make sense but like a lot of the
interface is built around the co-op so
your characters all individually have
their own piles of gold so when you go
shop and their own inventories and stuff
so when you go shopping shopping can be
a little bit of a hassle because I'm
like I'm constantly juggling around it's
like oh I just want to make it easy and
sell this thing thing and and or pay for
this thing oh no this character doesn't
have enough gold I have to start moving
gold around but is that the level of of
like the things that you're you don't
like about this game is just like
Inventory management is there anything
that's standing out at the moment it's
the inventory management a little bit of
the sometimes the game doesn't catch up
on the choices I've made like okay I've
finished this Quest why do you still
have this line of conversation that I
can always go through over and over
again it's like so but that's little
teeny stuff like the amount of content
and the way like my can I tell you a
little story about this game so so
there's this whole Quest towards the
beginning of the game where you have to
go you know you're you're you're doing
this murder mystery and you can talk to
dogs and stuff if you have the
appropriate uh the appropriate skill
Murdered Soul Suspect yeah yeah can you
make the cat go meow meow meow meow
Kevin can you make the kaco meow meow
meow meow you actually can yes oh my God
but not the same facial animation we
need we need another new that it doesn't
have your F your favorite animation
everybody watching this should go to my
murder till
over the lobby and look at the cat yeah
of course after the lobby so in so
anyway so in this graveyard I go up and
there's this woman she's like all boohoo
about whoever died this was something
she in a graveyard she's just like
boohoo and she's I talk to
her and I'm talking to her and so so in
RPGs you're used to like you you ha when
you go past the the graveyard and people
are [__] crying get over yourself
neyar buzz but you know I mean you know
how happen over there okay look I'm
talking now Tom it's not about you
Kevin's got a story spin your yarn yeah
I'm done now you don't love me okay so I
it is so Ser seriously like so there's
there there's like the game has a lot of
consequences that you're not used to all
right okay look in RPGs you're used to
consequences but not used to like really
vast consequences so I'm like oh she's
boohoo I have a shovel now so I'm going
to dig up the grave she boohoo hooing
about you're not used to like these kind
of consequences even even in the best
RPGs they usually not real consequences
for that kind of thing so I dig up the
grave and she's immediately how dare you
defile my loved one and she's like
combat starts and I like kill her with
like one axe blow what is this is
amazing and then I and then I and then I
loot the corpse and there's a bone in it
and I'm like I just killed this innocent
woman and dug up the and dug up the
grave for goddamn bone you know what you
do with bones you grind them up and use
them and stuff sure in correct that's it
I Divinity original sin is the game game
of the year game of the year right there
it's allowed Kevin to be a piece of [__]
in video gam so bad to do the past do
you know what it does though is it makes
you think about every single thing you
do now I'm like did it make you think
about that when you slept that night all
right no more div say I want to talk
about another game that involves digging
up bones at Wolfenstein Wolfenstein New
Order yeah have you played that I have
played I really enjoyed Wolfenstein or
wolfy times as we call it in this office
I only started playing Wolfie times on
Saturday uh it's fun so far but why is
it one of the best games released this
year what I really like about it is that
it's a game that's it's very aware of
its own place in history it's respectful
of the Wolfenstein tradition it Embraces
that kind of stuff but it doesn't find
itself like anchored down by it like it
actually it it's it pulls off this
Balancing Act between the bombast and
the machis moo like a Vint from the 9s
but it's also a game with a very
interesting story and very like BJ
Blasco is a great character in this game
which is not something that I was
expecting in the least like this this
game does like it does downtime really
well like very often you go you spend
time between missions in the uh in a hub
world or like a it's it's not a hub
world it's like a resistance hideout in
the middle of Berlin and it's like it's
you just linger there for a little while
and you hang out with these other
resistance Fighters and you kind of see
how they spend time you know in the
resistance it's it's it's really really
impressive and I about the actual like
shooting the shooting is really good
yeah yeah it's really good um the the
the chaos and like insanity of
Wolfenstein is all there the dual
wielding of massive Auto shotguns you
can do that and just totally go crazy
the way guys explode is really
upsettingly like real it's super yeah
and the thing is like and that's part of
what I really love about BJ blaskowitz
as a character in this game is that he's
he's a really he's a really interesting
character but he's not like a guy who's
like weighed down by his own dark past
he's not he he's not like tormented by
his own like inner turmoil he's he's a
guy who as one of your uh Side
characters remarks he was born to kill
Nazis great but he's also at the same
time he was born in the 40s yeah but
he's also like later probably
later the 10y olds out on the
battlefield 10y old it's like
three-year-old G but he's not a meathead
he's not like he's not an idiot he's a
very thoughtful contemplative guy who
expresses himself through these subdued
like inner monologues if I had traveled
from the past and heard you say this I
would have thought you were just talking
out of your
eyes that would have been the most
surprising thing if sea traveled from
the past yeah
I mean not be a good character Brazil
losing 60 in a World Cup semi-final
right now would probably be seven seven
I'd also like to point out that when we
travel in time we're always traveling
from the past God damn it godamn it
Kevin I want to travel to the past and
make sure this segment is shorter so
let's let's keep going keep it going
keep it going a game that Kevin vanard
uh was finishing last night as me and
Andy we're we're wrapping up our no
man's Sky edit H The Wolf Among Us yeah
speaking of wolfy times yeah speaking of
wolfy times that was a much better segue
than what I came up
with speaking of wolfy times Mary edit
it later The Wolf Among Us why is that
why is that one of the best games this
year because it seemed like when you
finished it that you weren't too no
spoilers on the most recent episode okay
I was disappointed with the finale but
the good news is that it doesn't wrap
things up in a very uh wrappy way did
you write that Kevin I did uppercut to
the I did write that I'm in the trailer
yeah yeah to I did write a
this was paid for wasn't it yeah but no
but seriously like it's I I think
overall even though I was a little
disappointed with the finale um I think
overall it is really one of those things
where the journey was totally worth it
it wasn't really about the destination
especially because the way it ends you
might want to then go back and and
replay stuff okay um which is not
something that I usually like to do with
a Telltale type game because I feel like
okay I've had my story I don't want to
mess with that story by like poking into
into the other possibilities cuz then I
like it's just like kind of pulling the
curtain and seeing the wizard um for me
so but it's it's really good um I think
the uh the third episode is actually the
Highlight for thir episode yeah yeah so
I would I would say definitely
especially because the world is just
really interesting and it got me into
the comics before uh let you guys go uh
would that be your favorite game with
the year then Kevin so far no I'd say
that so far I'm like kind of in a tossup
between uh Divinity original
and Dark Souls 2 oh okay and Sean what
about yourself honestly The Wolf Among
Us might be might be my top one so far
yeah sweet all right lots of votes of
wol Among Us H thanks very much
gentlemen for uh coming out here and
talking about uh the next I was about to
say the next big game the game of the
year halftime wrap-up special of course
we do game of the month every month
right here on gspot.com so make sure you
stay on the website and see what's going
to win this one what's going to win this
month yo guys what's going vinity is
going to win this month spoilers win
what else comes out this month no bunch
of games that aren't Divinity look
Divinity got to check in first so you
got oh my God sorry that big laran
Studio big laran studios marketing money
all that laran dollar all that laran
dollar singular got a right here Mary
Kish speaking you know maybe Mary has a
game that's going to win game of the
years no I can't believe I lost I can
cuz you suck of you sorry what's coming
out this wait s is coming out evil
because good is good and evil is dumb
you're not
evil he got me
again this is the game that will
probably win this is potato salad
because it's one it's made $60,000 in
like the last few days could you explain
that for folks who maybe don't have the
content there's a Kickstarter with a guy
that's uh raising money to make potato
salad and at first it was a joke so
people thought it would be funny to
share it but now this dude's making
sweet money and he's going to be sending
like thousands of packets of potato
salad to people over the mail wow I bet
that's not going to be depressing for
him whatsoever they are kickstarters
that can't make like five grand this guy
is going to make like 100k making potato
salad I guess we found out the secret
solves and it's got was always what
video games is coming out this week why
is coming out as you can see I'm going
the wrong
way the most important I mean we're not
even playing it's National Treasure
edition of saints R 4 I assume that's
going to be really cool we haven't
played it so I don't know that too much
about it um but that one is coming out
we can uh roll the footage and show
little bit I assume it will have
Nicholas Cage uh if it's National
Treasure Edition that's the least they
can do uh but it is coming out with uh
29 DLC Packs including like some of the
popular missions like enter the
Dominatrix and how the Saints save
Christmas uh plus you get a whole bunch
of weapons and vehicles all sorts of
stuff so it's 30 bucks for all that DLC
that sweet sweet DLC so so it's it's
worth picking up especially if you're a
fan of the Saints Row series and who
isn't who isn't
probably your good old pal Straw Hat
Luffy what game is this what's what one
uh this is a a very famous series one
piece series and their latest is
unlimited World red some people actually
find these really peeling Danny I'm sure
they do but when you say it's really
famous I feel like you ever if you ever
call something really famous it's not
really famous it is it's like if you say
it's famous get mcraft is kind of like a
mix between Tetris and Lemmings you're
getting the mice to the cheese using
like Tetris blocks um but unfortunately
kind of like you know Lemmings had um
mless creatures this one has like cute
little mice what the god what that's the
Wheel racing that happens in Cloud
Chester
shyon is it gluster yeah they like roll
the cheese and go after it I like how
you said glow Chester like everyone
there's got glowcoma or something
Glouchester sh senton and then red
solstice this is eight player co-op
which I like cuz it's actually really
hard for me to find good co-op games so
I thought this was worth mentioning cuz
and people who want to play them with
you yes
a sad I have seven friends Danny
I my mom my dad sister and super combo
man this game actually looks really sick
um you use your fanny pack as a weapon
great uh that means something where I'm
from what's a fanny pack where you're
from uh I don't know ask my
ex-girlfriend would if I asked you to
back that fanny pack up what would that
mean yeah I've said that many times
worked out real good oh yeah nobody
likes nobody wants that fanny pack we
going to back it up let's back up out of
this section before we say something
even worse all right well that went
really well okay see you guys see you
Mary Mary kiss there everyone's favorite
she makes uh new releases fun even when
there's only three four games coming out
most of them DLC ridiculous uh well we
have games spots resident Jesus here so
we're just gonna don't say anything for
the moment because people we're going to
go for it in a second and people will be
wondering what your voice is so you
could you could have like a real deep
voice you could have like a real
freakishly high pitch voice nobody will
know Jeremy Jane is a
whole whole new ball game see what
happens we'll be back in a second and
we're going to check out some of the
Fantastic life programming happening on
gamespot.com not just this one left his
block oh Jesus Christ [__]
[__]
fairos to not jump on that that thing
shoot jump it jump it
broke oh they were being
dicks oh [__] you get the [__] out of
here the night that was really good l
king that was pretty sweet her and Peter
played that uh bro force was on multiple
players the Sha method earlier
today what was what was we play The
Stomp stomping L stomping l oh that's
the dinosaur one that's sucked really
yeah God damn it h random caner on
tomorrow next car game I'm going to
shoot black holes and stuff H now
playing we've got a counter spy uh which
was cool we had that at E3 as well it
was pretty good and hes hars on Sunday
unless it's Saturday if you're actually
in AU or it's Monday I don't know time
is weird freaks Frights and maybe a few
screams pretty sure that's a vague
description and not the name of an
actual video game that's pretty good all
that and more right here on gam
sport.com want to remind the folks at
home if they want to win one of those
humble B let's try that again go back to
the gy go back to the gy
jib jib one of the process of
elimination son of a
[__] go back to jib hey
no it's not on you jibb's not on you
anymore it's not all about you Danny O
dwire J's all about me all right all
right go to a different camera yeah
there you go there we go want to remind
the folks at home if you want to Wi one
of those hum hle Bumble wow consist W
all for not consist where to go Danny
bumble hles
W all right let's go again from Top all
right here we go she sells she sells
want remind Folks
at maybe you should stop doing your fake
Irish accent sorry americ American oh I
should go back to my American accent I
want to remind of folks at home if you
want to win one of those Humble Bundle
codes to make sure you
retweet who invited Joe
peshy go on to gam spot's Twitter can
make sure you retweet what we done
tweeted uh at 9:15 earlier today to win
one of those codes you can win a bunch
of games did a whole show from the jib
at this stage MH
regardless I'm very happy to be joined
by gamespot's own foresting expert
Jeremy Jane jezza how are you doing my
friend I'm doing wonderful man it's good
to be here H you did a fantastic feature
last week about Forest about uh it's a
game a bunch of us start playing last
week it's a bunch of fun Sean you played
it as well I played it on the Sha method
uh your piece was a lot more ful than
mine I really just shouted at the sex
demon yeah that's that's a lot of what I
did that was behind the camera you I
didn't put that at the piece cuz I
needed to you know maintain an a of
seriousness but it was all sex demon on
the back so we've been playing a bunch
of this and like I think like
unanimously none of us have like ever
manage to SP to like last longer than
four or five days like I I seem I seem
to be able to kill the cannibals pretty
good with Molotov and I'm like 50 logs
into building my cabin and then just 20
of them turn up it's like and you run
out of lizards to eat and you start
trying to eat cannibals you become a
cannibal slowly throughout the game but
it doesn't allow you to eat people
unfortunately true that's a feature that
needs to be implemented I think well
it's an alpha at the moment so who knows
what's going to come you can eat people
in beta I'm calling
it all right so let's jump in I've I've
got a a challenge for you wait I've been
waiting to open this
table the best oh go so high Christ if
you want no you're showing off our
shameful inside of the table oh there's
weights in there if you want carp T you
should definitely it's probably EAS you
know I was thinking about carbal tunnel
but this this works too all right I got
a challenge for you we're going to start
on one side of the island okay and
you're going to have to try and run to
the other side okay of the island all
right that sounds good I try and get
there yeah there is a uh there is quite
a long load time in this game it's
building all my sweet inventory items it
builds the video game yeah it's it's
actually someone's someone's making a
video game right now there's not
actually that much stuff you can craft
like molotovs I you can make like bombs
out of the circuit
boards I cheated and went to their Wiki
and basically had like the the crafting
right and there was only like three or
four different things in there yeah um
I've been relying on molotovs I didn't
even know you could make bombs I feel
like an amateur at this game now but uh
I've not done it yet you can throw
tennis balls yeah you can it's a weird
kind of it really really feels like an
alpha like some games on I feel steam R
access don't but this one really does
yeah well it it it feels very complete
in a lot of ways but there's not that
much to do yet oh my God everyone says
this TV is so dark when I watch this and
now I finally understand their pain oh
it's night time wait up for a second I'm
not sure if we're actually getting
gameplay yet Oh's no point doing a
challenge if you can't actually see the
video game do anything I'm going to do
all the cool stuff now yeah oh my God I
can't believe you you're actually making
love to the sex Beast really finally a
feature that's ridiculous this is a
pretty sweet cabin that we can't see on
the all right oh someone's taking over
the mouse there's a poltergeist in the
studio H so you talked a lot about sort
of the the the possibilities of how fun
this game might be in you know future
it's it's fun now seems like type of
game you can play for maybe a couple of
hours and then get bored off what would
you like to see implemented uh well I
know they're going to implement Co-op
eventually which is something that I'm
really excited for uh I think it'd be a
lot of fun just because games like this
where there's not a ton to do but they
sort of hand you the tools and say do
what you will is a lot more fun when you
have another person because there's sort
of a social element so even something
like Grand Theft Auto that's already
fleshed out you know you're playing it
alone you know you do everything there
is to do and you get sort of bored after
a while but you know if you're playing
with a buddy you can just sort of like
create your own experience and sort of
just talking about the game becomes this
whole narrative aspect that doesn't you
know exist when you're alone I guess it
depends how to sort of implement it
because you've played games like rust
for instance which is a game that a lot
of people think has actually been
hampered by the fact that other people
get involved like it it becomes kind of
I don't know a bit of a crazy there
becomes a huge barrier to entry when
there's so many people and you're
they're all killing you immediately and
suddenly the learning curve goes like
that whereas a game like Forest if it's
just 2 three four player co-op then I
think to Jeremy's point it would serve
the game and the tool set a lot better H
it seems like in the like in the release
they have at the moment uh are we we're
able to go all right and the wonderful
thing about post is come back here come
back on this one come back on this one
one thing about post is I'm going to
call all cut all this out you're never
going to know what happened there you go
bam secrets to the Internet so Jeremy
here you are look at your inventory I am
going to cook a lizard because I'm
planning on going a little journey here
and uh are you going to do it at night
time are you going to sleep until the
day you know I am going to throw that
lizard in the fire and take a little nap
see what happens hopefully it'll become
day all right look at that beautiful
streaming light why did sometimes when I
fell asleep it was still the night time
you know I think you slept through the
entire day okay and you were just a lazy
bastard D but as you see I've spent the
two hours before the show constructing a
perimeter around my little base it took
a very long time too long to admit on
the air will that actually stop them
from coming in you know I have not held
off any sort of Siege against them but
uh in the trailer I've seen them JP over
entire wall so I don't think there's
really a point except for the illusion
of security which is the most important
also the fact that you haven't actually
closed the loop here not only have a
door but just though the fire stops them
it's a trap okay well they catch on fire
it doesn't actually stop them oh well
that's great cuz then you just have a
house full of people on fire exactly
which is exactly what I've always wanted
so we're here on you know well there's
no map so we're here on a coast I don't
know what cardinal direction and we're
just going to go for a little hike you
know maybe find some cannibals I don't
really know what's going to happen this
is the forest I do want to point out in
my experience one of the most powerful
weapons you can use in the game is the
leg Sean I'm glad you said that because
I took a pro tip out of your book here
and uh I grabbed a leg before the stream
started oh oh de oh no oh the leg is too
powerful leg is op froze the game well
that that's a good game right there
that's oh we're good we're good we're
good just a loading hitch just just you
have no idea which direction you're
pointed in loading is one of the
wonderful features in this Al a build of
the forest exactly also you know before
we get too far Sean I found out a little
thing that I don't think you even know
after playing much of this game chop
down trees yeah well that too Danny but
I found out someone said you could climb
trees and I thought it was [__] so I
decided to test it out and you can't
quite climb a tree but and excuse me
home it takes a long time to cut down a
tree in this game if you've ever played
this game you're sick of clicking your
mouse button all
right what you can do sweet jumps off
trees and ride them yeah the Pioneers
used to ride those things man I think
the cannibals can I think I saw one but
you you just hack climb or you Mash
space button as a tree falls all right
so you start this game in a plane crash
we've decided to make you walk from
coast to coast exactly so you start in
that plane and you come to and a a
cannibal is taking your son well
presumably your son it's just a small
boy I have no could be any small boy
that you're hanging out with he is
sleeping on your arm when you start the
game though so like I said any small boy
it could be any small boy and only you
two are on the plane also uh worth
noting that there's a dead starus and
your semi- living body on the plane and
this cannibal decides to take a small
child I'm not there's a lot more meat on
that adult lady than on that child I
mean maybe it's like a ve thing he's
tender but you have a pedometer here and
I'm repurposing it as a pedo meter to
find piles in the woods because they
took my boy so I'm going to eat some
berries here are they okay for you are
they I never read the survival book
about berries I don't really care I just
eat berries if they pop up you know
maybe the poison will you hav the poison
ones are the ones that are like pairs of
berries you want like the big bunch oh
they got rid of my leg got get another
say you're not equipped a leg Yeah no
I'm not properly equipped to have you
already reached our Coast you know it
looks like maybe I was on some sort of
peninsula day I think maybe you need to
turn right so there's usually cannibals
hanging out by the wait this is this is
where you camped isn't this no no cuz
see oh I can't further down I somehow
got there's always the around here yeah
so let's let's continue down the beach
here maybe we'll find a cave with a good
sex demon in it and for people at home
the sex demons are just sort of these
weird they're not actually called sex
demons this is actually the cave
entrance if you wanted really sweet
Jesus let's go spalin guys spalin with a
human leg speaking of sex demons all
right so this is weird you go through
the water and if this is the cave I
think of yep there you go you just dry
land all of a sudden yeah have you has
any of you managed to actually murder
this thing there godam it no it's not
that's those are just regular demons not
sex demons get get out there get out
there get out get
there we don't they hang out during the
day my
ass oh mama all right well let's just
let's continue a little hike here this
is just a little I think they in the
cave I think it actually loads a
separate world when you go in there I
think so too I'm just going to pretend
that they're just territorial though and
that that's a oh look at that dude he's
dead dead body can I oh God what's
what's happening there I hacked him
apart with a leg am I holding his legs
look down
again no look down no no no no just look
straight yeah yeah and then now look
down and don't hit anything it looks
like youve got a leg for a dick wait
wait equip the head equip the head there
you go oh yeah equip the head this wait
wait wait
now look out into the sunset and now
slowly down a slow romantic moment oh
hello there oh hey there buddy what are
you what are you doing down there you
just keep doing your you keep doing what
you it's amazing you landed on this
island and you don't have anything but a
flashlight oh and you know what I'm I'm
starving to death here yeah you know
only the essentials Dan you got to pack
light when you're going to crash in a
plane sure a the forest oh the forest
you can do it you can reach the other
side of this island you know the other
side I'm going to be honest with you is
an invisible wall but maybe we'll find
something cool on the way to that
invisible wall it's not a bad the
destination is it it's the journey look
at those toenails I didn't even notice
that oh that's nasty oh sweet jeez yeah
those are gross those are gross I think
if you spend as much time living in
caves your toenails probably wouldn't be
as long as those are a climbing
Implement oh what's that is that Thunder
there's yeah it's a weird visual glitch
that happened a lot to me too it's like
lightning but it happens during the day
yeah exactly it sort of just created
like weird blue towers for me when the
lightning went off it didn't actually
load in the lightning yeah I want to
mention the folks at home if you have
any questions by all means uh stick them
in the chat we'll get right to them uh
next next person you see I want you to
beat them up with a leg Yeah I'm I'm
just trying to find trouble now man how
uh how long have you survived in this
save file oh God I don't even know cuz
it doesn't tell you the actual number of
days till you die cuz I think the
cannibals get more aggressive over time
because they're they are like they're
observant at first they'll watch you
from afar and as they kind of like you
see a dude you see a man or is that go
over there I think straight over there
field I this is where I tried to make my
log cabin but then I realized that I'd
built it very very close to a encampment
of actual oh little village but
sometimes they're not there and then
it's even freakier yeah yeah that's the
real scare the ambient scare have you
seen any of the um the tennis ball
Effigies uh tennis ball Effigies
somebody else was playing I think it was
you that showed me actually it was uh I
saw one where it was basically a bunch
of uh like bodies with like tennis
rackets through them like and they were
dressed up as tennis people like
everyone else on the flight was going to
like some tennis academy they got fed
man they hacked him apart I don't see
any dudes at this little village this
little dude Village little dude Village
a village of dudes is that the invisible
wall over there to the left is that
where we're going we refy over there on
that island oh right here yeah this
little thing right here I was looking
too far oh delightful look at that
that's a human head that lovely lady she
uh that's probably not my son although
his hair may have grown since I last saw
him I think I think he managed to
actually Circle the entire Island I
think so too and I don't see any
cannibals pretty good I like it maybe
this is the tactic everyone wanted to
know about it's ridiculous Affinity on
Twitch asks due to cannibals respawn can
you kill all of them I have no idea I
have killed a lot of cannibals and they
just keep coming I don't think there's a
finite number on the island I think that
they're just they're constantly boning
in that cave and making new cannibals
yeah and they have a quick asexual
reproduction cycle they don't even need
to Bone man I mean that's all the sex
demon right there exactly wait are you
like destroying this footage CU you're
carrying the foot you know I think that
is just my naturally sharp
torso
gag lington asks can you chew on the
toenails for extra health I hope so God
where are all these cannibals man
thought this was the forest not what's
going on just the forest so they've
patched it apparently and they got rid
of the cannibals well they do have vegan
mode which is you can just load in and
there are no cannibals is that a real
thing yeah that is a real thing I swear
to God honestly I swear to God totally I
would not do that to you Danny not on
the air not like this it's amazing oh
[__] go to an open plane go to an open
area all right I'm going to keep keep
hunting for for the cannibals man not
stopping this stream until we see here's
an open area I see some om ominous
lightning come on
boys see the thing is when I'm playing
this game every single time I don't want
to see a cannibal I see a goddamn canni
oh me too that's why I'm so confused
like none of them here it's like I think
Sean might be right I think they all
might be boning in that cave I think so
too I slept multiple days in
anticipation of finding some cannibals
wa that was a pretty decent jump there
jump you can like you can like can you
kick for that
can you do a hard flip I think that's in
version three I guess this is version
three or it's version 03 Mr troll gaming
asks on Gamespot what is your favorite
feature in the game what do you think
first Sean I personally I like being
able to use uh legs as a
weapon it's something that you don't
often see in video games my favorite
feature was the sort of uh the like I
don't know not knowing what to do in
these games is fun like not knowing the
rules not knowing how you know when the
cannibal is going to come what happens
like the first time you die and you
appear in the cave like all that wonder
and I guess the sort of frustrating
thing about playing an alpha is no keep
going that way don't no I have an idea
I'm going to first time you die in this
game it transports you to a cave full of
zombies K sex demons as the case may be
I am going to up here and contemplate
Beauty and suicide at the same time kick
flip I think you actually landed outside
the cave as well they're probably just
going to drag me in there yeah to meet a
sex demon all right so you come to and
it's real dark and it's like hey why
don't you just hit L use your lighter
and sometimes you know it's a little
little less little less atmospheric here
but uh mind you got a dual wield a ax
and a light there you go yeah there we
go it is dark and here start as [__] you
know what's going to happen right you
know what's going to happen going be
you're going to get out of here Scot
free well there's a bunch of oh there's
a bunch of dead people well you've
collected loads of them how many have
you seen now uh I think there
I've only seen six in this Save State
why won't it let me use my flashlight
man whatever H Ned Booka asks between uh
da Z rust and this which is more better
SL enjoyable Sean what do you think
first um I mean my favorite game of the
bunch is probably rust um but I don't I
don't think this game is quite as far
along enough to compare to Daisy and
rust because those ones have just had so
much more time to iterate did you just
fall through the level I don't know if
I'm going right
it is very dark oh you know what I might
should I load it up I think you fell
through the level I think I fell I don't
even know what's going on right now look
look up look up that's like totally
that's the underside of the table am I
on the
ceiling I think we found a wormhole
Danny oh oh am I dead I honestly cannot
see one day baby nice work in many ways
that is the most appropriate uh demo of
of uh the you can have nothing happened
and then you fell through the the floor
but it was a nice hike wasn't it that
was a beautiful hike can we have a quick
discussion about the state of buying
alpha games you can pay $15 spend 30
minutes and not see a single zombie I'm
just throwing it out there that's that's
that's that's gaming man right there
I've uh I've enjoyed my time with the
forest but I will say that I think I'm
kind of done with it until it comes out
yeah yeah I would well personally I
think that if people are interested in
playing it that maybe they should
probably wait a while I think so yeah I
totally agree yeah they need to
implement more features I think when
Co-op comes back it seems like that's
something that they're already working
into the game so I think that'll be in
pretty soon but like until that's in or
until they Implement a lot more
buildings right now all you can really
do is eat kill zombies survive or
cannibals I'm sorry and uh build a house
boat that doesn't do anything well if
you want to see a more action-packed uh
demo then by all means watch the Sha
method on kmart.com I feel so bad for
Jeremy he spent two hours two hours
walls I fought off so maybe maybe I
fought them all off yeah it's maybe all
right Jeremy since you're here we got a
bunch of people who won Humble Bundle
stuff all right let go for it read them
all out all right all of these people
are winners at Howard Hughes Jr at C
rraw you don't have to do ad every time
okay really it's not going to tag them
on Twitter if I don't say the ad though
oh don't read don't read uh this one
right here okay I'm all right Alex rhs
or rids 185 Bob Jones 198 Stan G 205
mirala King tentacle king of all of the
tentacles dizzy Ostro armchair soups
who's chilling an armchair somewhere
right now me right now sure yeah it's
that's actually just Danny he won uh
Dimitri Rose wall caller 01 James Knack
Clinton Pat God you guys give away a lot
of [__] on this uh sakatumi oh I
told you not to read that one oh we got
to put sake Tumi in his place all right
I I resend that one he actually didn't
win yeah sorry buddy Neo jet Angel uh
unclad rough reader um who is the most
literary of the Rough Riders uh Nik de
mores that's DMX's uh book club actually
woy Zars X going read it to
you and finally vinto 316 wonderful
thank you so much we'll get you on to
demo a game that's actually finished
next time has enemies somewhere in it
God damn it apparently Brazil lost 71 in
the end 71 consolation gold how bad H
thank you very much for watching the
lobby today oh what's going on oh yeah I
forgot we've got like a bunch of uh
World of Warcraft uh uh Warlords of dror
codes left over actually if you go to
gamespot.com dror giveaway that's a new
URL it's got new codes on it h get in
there and you can get in on that beta
make sure that you also have Mr pandar
installed already because sadly uh you
need Dash to get in on that bad boy as
well is that cool Cynthia we got it all
right the lobby this week rambling crazy
ridiculous
Meandering exp this is what happens when
you spend I me and Andy were just
editing all the past two days very very
tired thank you very much for watching
as ever enjoy those codes H we'll be
back next week with more uh video games
and hopefully ones that are actually
finished adios have a great
week we out DMX
EX
know